die kanone die aus china zählt ist
längst verstummt und auch verrostet aber
die alte angst ist nun zurück und herr
chen macht sich gedanken wo er sich
verstecken könnte wenn tatsächlich die
chinesen kommen vielleicht hier unten im
bunker den kennt davon früher der
tröpfelt an manchen stellen trinkwasser
herein das könnte leben retten
da war für ein auffangbecken für wasser
in der regenzeit sickert das
normalerweise hier durch und wird da
aufgefangen und
essbare wurzeln gibt es da draußen davon
könnte man sich eine zeit lang ernähren
meint er
penn war soldat auf der insel masur dem
letzten vorposten taiwans und schon fast
in rufweite der chinesischen küste wo
vielen touristen heute ein schauer über
den rücken läuft
[Musik]
das alles da drüben ist das festland die
insel punkt an ihre windräder das ist ja
so nah das schockiert mich
lange rechneten sie hier mit einem
angriff der chinesin gegen den sie alles
auf boten sogar glassplitter an denen
sich die invasoren die hände
aufschlitzen sollten aber dann ab anfang
der 90er wurde es immer friedlicher
wurden die soldaten abgezogen die über
90 bunker nach und nach stillgelegt
nummer 55 ist heute eine herberge kann
ich ja kein zootier siehst du das
fenster da war früher mal eine
schießscharte bei der renovierung haben
wir es verbreitet aber unlängst kam ein
brief vom verteidigungsministerium
darin steht die armee könnte den bunker
55 wie auch die anderen von der
regierung den zivilisten überlassenen
bunker zur vorbereitung auf einen krieg
beschlagnahmen
neuerdings gibt es in march auch immer
mehr wehrübungen all das seit beginn des
ukraine kriegs
aggressive diktatur überfällt
demokratischen nachbarn für die 23
millionen taiwaner mehr als eine horror
vision
spätestens seit peking hongkong
völkerrechtswidrig unterworfen hat war
jedem klar dass präsident sie ernst
machen wollte mit der so genannten
wiedervereinigung darüber und über den
krieg in der ukraine wird hitzig
debattiert in taiwans fernsehstudios
einen vorteil habe taiwan meinen manche
hier wollen keinen krieg wir können
einen krieg sogar verhindern denn die
kommunistische partei chinas hat einen
schwachpunkte sie kann das risiko nicht
eingehen
denn wenn ihr waffengang gegen taiwan
scheitert wird das für die
kommunistische partei chinas eine
riesige katastrophe
das bärige taiwan ist eine natürliche
festung panzer können hier nicht
einrollen große lande operationen sind
unmöglich aber eine seeblockade könnte
die insel nur einen monat überstehen
während womöglich feindliche truppen
einsickern
[Musik]
erst jetzt wird vielen klar dass sich
dann jeder seiner haut wird erwehren
müssen sowie in der ukraine
straßenkampf seminare mit
waffenattrappen sind gerade ausgebucht
seit die wehrpflicht auf vier monate
verkürzt wurde kennt sich kaum noch
einer aus mit kriegsgerät
wenn ein krieg ausbricht und ich bleibe
zu hause wer geht dann für mich raus
dieses training schafft für uns ein déjà
vu sie lernen in der praxis und haben
dann keine angst mehr das ist kein krieg
aber okay das habe ich schon mal
mitgemacht also habe ich weniger angst
zur nahkampf übung hat er sich noch
nicht gemeldet aber den kampfgeist und
den zusammenhalt der ukraine so wundert
auch justin
diese ukrainischen bürger berühren mich
möglich
ist dass ein ganzes volk sein land
verteidigen kann sein territorium
das ist möglich
ich finde das hat eine enorme power
das macht einem echten mode
eifrig studiert er die fibeln der
regierung die ihrem friedliebendes volk
die elementarsten militärischen
grundbegriffe nahe bringen muss zum
beispiel wie man freund und feind
auseinander hält
gibt es erläuterungen und zeichnungen
sieht man unsere uniformen und auch die
chinesischen armee damit man die
unterscheiden kann
das ist nützlich
sehr nützlich
heutzutage wissen die meisten nicht mal
mehr wie die taiwanesischen uniformen
aussehen für alle weiteren fragen hat
jeder bezirk einen beauftragten ernannt
der soll über alles auskunft geben
können theoretisch wie justin long
feststellt sind beim diensthabenden
zivilschützer in seiner nachbarschaft
noch einige wissenslücken zu beklagen
und wenn es wirklich gibt
wie informiert ihr dann das viertel in
welcher schutzräume sie fliehen können
das weiß ich nicht so genau das ist für
jedes viertel anders ich zum beispiel
habe keine lautsprecheranlage
da bin ich nicht ganz sicher
was es tatsächlich zu einer großen
katastrophe kommt oder einem krieg
dann hapert es wohl mit der
reibungslosen information über die luft
schutzräume
auf drastische art macht ein grüppchen
exil ukrainer mitten in taipeh für jeden
verständlich wie ein grausamer krieg
schlagartig alles verändern alles
beenden kann auch justin long ist
beeindruckt
autokratische länder fangen leicht
krieger an
nachdem wir putins tagen gesehen haben
machen wir uns große sorgen china könnte
sich gegenüber teilhaben genau so
aufführen
wir haben große angst
denn plötzlich ist er ganz nah
dieser krieg auf der anderen seite der
welt
[Musik]